hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Lauren for
Cheska Lauren Francesca from the channel
I want my Lauren is here hey George
so is my dog I I'm sorry this is the
most professional YouTube channel ever
and your dog is making too much noise
raka raka one of my favorite sketch
comedy channels I got sent this and I
realized I never saw this video that
they did a few months ago and I love
these guys
have you ever seen raka raka no you're
in for it violent tree Ronald McDonald
murders howtobasic uncut have you heard
of howtobasic
yeah yeah so are you gonna collab video
they did together it might be a collab
video either way of watching collabs
that's cool I don't know how violent
this is gonna be chances are because
it's raka raka they're gonna go all out
warning this video contains violent
scenes that may offend some viewers
major sick TIFF I'll make an exercise
actors props okay how do you basic it is
a sketch or make you put it out to basic
Oh horrible this is the words I'm gonna
get sick mama McDonald murders how to
basic
is that healthy basin yes sir I've never
seen the actual weirdest thing on
YouTube I've ever heard in my life ever
Oh gross yeah I warned you to be violet
Oh how much longer is this a minute more
this is really bad
you
that made me nauseous
hey yeah I feel sick right now there
were parts of that video where I thought
I was gonna throw up all over your couch
oh wow that was really gross like are
all his videos like this or raka raka
tends to go really violent what I notice
about their sketches is they have this
funny concept because Ronald McDonald is
one of the reoccurring characters and
they're like what if Ronald McDonald
murdered howtobasic like it just sounds
funny but then they really commit to the
concept and they go all out with the
gore and stuff how you feeling I feel
honestly I know we watched the video
about masturbation it's like the
weirdest things like like I ever want to
watch a really weird video on the
internet and be like okay what's the
weirdest [ __ ] like you can find and I
know you will know what it is like I
never like saw anything like that
McDonald's is my favorite place to eat
like ever really it was really
disturbing to see like Ronald McDonald
do things like that too you know was
that that sexy guy like it's really sad
like you think I was a basic sexy oh
yeah it's totally sexy oh nice yeah for
you hey maybe you could collab with him
if you're watching how to basis yeah
he's still alive if he's not in the like
bathtub like I get like I can't watch
scary things I just get like I just
closed my eyes and I like just like I'm
like tell me what it's over
yeah that was pretty gross that is worse
there's like real-life Mortal Kombat
fatalities
there's Ronald McDonald playground
slaughter is this all his videos or
different people's videos it's Iraq Iraq
is a group of people oh yeah well I
think the grossest part of the video for
you when you pulled the teeth oh I close
my eyes I can't watch I can't watch it
like that like I was actually kind of
shocked I didn't really react because
anything with teeth pulling like just
freaks me out or like anything with the
mouth you know yeah I didn't I I closed
my eyes like the leg thing and when he'd
like the egg fell like from in between
his legs yeah tomato or something I
thought it was an a I guess was a tomato
it was like so the food I felt like the
food stuff at the beginnings were gross
to you out the most not the actual
violence like why are you doing that to
my hamburgers what's your favorite thing
in McDonald's Big Mac oh nice good what
about you oh man you know sometimes when
I move for number two you know two
cheeseburgers I don't really like
pickles and onions but I get extra
ketchup on it I really do like the
breakfast the two sausage McMuffin with
that combo since again an extra hash
brown you know sometimes you still
hungry but not like 24-hour breakfast
because it's like am i excited about it
it launched a while ago and yeah I have
taken advantage of the 24-hour breakfast
it is the most awesome thing McDonald's
has ever done but Ivanoff soda for 21
days oh wow I'm sorry we mean you're
sorry that's an amazing right it's
amazing but how are you like you're okay
yeah I was very really hard at first but
I'm getting through it guys without your
guys's support yeah even though you guys
didn't know about it I want to be here
right now
yeah how to basic they do like these
weird like how-to videos that just
involves like smashing [ __ ] I think it's
a great collab for people who are fans
of both channels what's the most violent
movie you've seen and I really watch
that many violent things do you watch
like BDSM enough cutting back on the
vulgarity here but I could talk about me
yeah Brock and I can sometimes get very
just violent in the bedroom like I'm
talking like rack Arrakis tile she just
starts pounding on I'll be really into
it like the more blood there is the
better nice when she's on her period
okay that's very good yeah as I cross
the line I mean that's how Veronica
feels bad baby
what does okay if I talk about your
period yeah he's pretty cool girlfriend
there's a time of the month when
Veronica and I really just make pure
passionate love it's great nice to meet
you guys
yeah oh you can watch if you want
oh yeah go too far baby yeah I'm sorry
I'm sorry Veronica Lauren you shouldn't
have let me go so far I blame you for my
jokes anyway guys thanks for tuning into
the channel listen if you're new to it
click this button to subscribe and
become a rejected a Lauren Francesca has
a channel called I want my Lauren it's
almost as high quality as production as
my videos slightly they're just a little
bit more a little bit more in your
sketches you know like your crew and all
that they're almost up to par with my
crew
yeah you should subscribe to me guys um
I don't make videos like the the ones we
just watched now she makes really funny
sketches I make funny things I can't
watch this like gross stuff I did do a
movie that was a horror movie that like
there's lots of blood and stuff so I can
act in it but I just can't watch you get
killed in it I don't want to give away
the ending guys I don't want to tell you
what happens okay okay horror movie are
rated pg-13
like I don't think it's rated nudity
lots of nudity really yeah I'm not mean
are you though right okay like girls no
racist movie that's what that is don't
you know that primarily the real rejects
is a black demographic I didn't know
that yeah I'm just like it's not my
fault that they like Italian girls right
like Rihanna's like it's alright it's
very close it's very very close yeah
yeah
what do black that's like Italian girls
I don't know cuz they're black too
what is it I don't know what is it it's
like I have no [ __ ] clue guys I don't
like talking about these things makes me
uncomfortable no more you're just like
fine and always make me feel
uncomfortable well it's because I saw
that you have some pretty raunchy
sketches so I thought there's got to be
a way where I can top her sketches and
actually get her to an uncomfortable
zone so I can feel proud of myself yeah
you did it I've done it
I'm Ryan right this is Lauren take care
now bye guys